thank you very much for coming I'm quite
happy that there are people in the room
today my going to talk about the
application of recurrent neural network
to innovative drug design so I'm going
through to go through some basic things
about the recurrent neural network in
the context of drug design in the
context of molecule chemical species
generation so let's go through the
agenda first I would like to say a few
words about my Who am I then we'll go
through the recurrent neural network
some quite general introduction some
equations as well
then I'd like to go through the some
generative approach in natural language
processing just to draw at the analogy
between standard language generation and
molecules generation so I'm hoping that
at the end you will see this connection
between these two worlds then a few
slides about the
recurrent neural networks in chemistry
and they are the final part the use case
of molecular generations so I'm going to
go through the smiles codes and I will
introduce the smiles representation of
chemical molecule then a few words about
the Python chem informatics libraries
and then we'll be generating the
molecules hopefully some drugs and then
at the end the summary so Who am I I am
a chemist actually I'm I come from
Natural Sciences I've done my PhD and
culture in Germany some years ago now
currently I am a competent center
manager at psi Paul's kind Poznan where
I led a team of advanced methodologies
team of analysts we apply a lot of
machine learning for industry problems
like timeseriesforecasting predictive
maintenance predictive quality
prescriptive maintenance and so on also
the multi criteria optimization fuzzy
logic and other advanced analytics and I
also work for Polish Academy of Sciences
or
I'm actually trying to apply the
recurrent neural network for drug design
which is the topic of today's
presentation also molecular dot
molecular docking and quantum
computational chemistry so let's go
through first I'd like to show this
tweet this is Francois shala who is the
inventor of Kara's he is very
pessimistic actually about AI and I tend
not to overuse the term artificial
intelligence I don't think that the
algorithmics we have now it's
intelligence in the human being sense I
would say this is just advanced
algorithmics so let's have this in mind
this is just my let's say also my point
of view the recurrent neural network
just a few thoughts the human being
brain usually does not learn a single
isolated information usually we have
some sort of context around and the
recurrent neural network is going to is
designed in such a way that is capable
of capturing the context the hide the
hidden layer which I'm going to
introduce soon is responsible for
catching this context and yeah one can
consider actually when thinking about
the recurrent neural networks
what various time steps the time series
might be lets say prototype very basic
object that is that is actually can be
the subject of the application of
recurrent neural network now I'm using
your Jupiter notebook with Rize this is
a plug in to Jupiter notebook which
allows on the execution of some script
so we are going to execute some scripts
actually during this talk this is a time
series a simple time series where we
have met or Audrey cow conditions like
temperature pressure this might be also
humidity precipitation or other things
just the time series and actually the
recurrent
neural network is very very capable of
capturing the Noblet which is embedded
in a time series and then we can
stimulate for example this recurrent
neural network to produce new species of
the same kind
the next I'm available at this time time
step with expected quantities which is
something like a forecasting so they are
very good algorithms for forecasting of
time series what's the structure of our
and then I will go very quickly through
some equations so we have the as usually
in deep learning we have a couple of
layers the output layer contains couple
the the couple of units which means that
we can predict the sequence so the the
key point is that we can introduce two
recurrent neural network the sequence
and at the output layer we can also get
the sequence it's computed computed in
in in the following way by the way you
have do we have the laser pointer do we
have the laser pointer no fine
so we have this whu-oh which is the
output connection matrix the hidden
state which I will be showing on the
next slide and then the bias of output
layer and as usual we apply the
activation function hyperbolic tangent
or something like this to get the final
response of our neural network when
doing a forward pass yeah so the
mysterious thing which is not available
in let's say multi-layer perceptron is
this hidden hidden layer and the hidden
layer is defined so in this way this HT
equals FH applied to ot so you can see
that we have additional activation
function
in addition to the one we saw at the
previous slide we have this OT which is
yeah just the standard matrix connecting
the input XT is the input this our
predictors the data we introduce to the
network so we have an additional matrix
whh which is applied to the HT minus one
which is actually the previous hidden
layer so we have to know this hidden
layer at the time step T we have to know
the hidden layer from the previous time
from the previous time step yeah we have
an additional hidden layer activation
function and the input layer is just the
the layer through which we introduce the
data so for example like in this time
series they had two two predictors or
two quantities like temperature and
pressure then we can imagine that we
have just two input nodes through which
we introduce the sequences and this is
important in the context of recurrent
neural network that we introduced the
sequences like in the multi-layer
perceptron we usually let's say
introduce the single time step and we
don't have we are not able to capture
the context which means the time steps
which are around so in the case of
recurrent neural network we introduce
entire sequence and at the end also we
can get the sequence as a prediction so
I'm not going to spend too much time on
this so I repeat this equation here we
have the connection two hidden layers so
yeah the one we introduced the predictor
then we instead of going to let's say
the next layer we have something like an
intermediate layer which is this hidden
layer which is actually responsible for
capturing the context information yeah
and then for this we have the matrix of
hidden states this whh yeah as you saw
in the previous slides applied on to the
hidden state of the previous time step
and as usually we have the bias which we
apply an additive component the key
equations so in the bottom
in the top we have the output layer so
this is the let's say the very end of
our four forward path so this is the the
YT is the prediction in the middle we
have the hidden layer which is yeah
applied to the OT I mean it's just
outcome of the application of hidden
layer activation function to the OT
which has been defined before and yeah
and also here so yes so a couple of
equations just to see this some
graphical representation we have R here
this incoming predictors like quantities
we want to introduce to the network and
then we have hidden layer with all these
quantities or matrices which are needed
like the W iterate and at the end we
have the outcoming
layer the output layer where we get the
predictions the training processes as
usual we have a loss function where we
which measures the error between the
real responses and predicted responses
and as usually we just calculate yeah we
use the
standard gradient descent approach where
we have to calculate the first
derivative of our loss function with
respect to the network parameters which
are the components of the matrices and
we have the generalization of back
propagation which is called the back
propagation through time because we have
to iterate over the time and this is a
problem because we have some problems
and issues associated with the recurrent
neural network so if we consider this
the simplest possible recurrent neural
network which is called vanilla
recurrent neural network the one I've
actually shown that equations then we
have the vanishing vanishing gradient
problem or exploding gradient problem
this is sort of a numerical
instabilities associated with learning
process and there are quite a few
recipes to go around these problems like
a more holistic approach to optimization
to putting some boundaries on the
network matrices but these are actually
some part works so in principle the
standard vanilla recurrent neural
network is not used that often these
days we have the lsdm the long
short-term memory unit which is actually
applied more often I will not go through
the slide in detail we have a lot more
matrices and a lot of network parameters
will introduce our predictors our
incoming quantities in couple of places
but as before we have the hidden state
and we have the prediction that the
output layer let's not go through this
math in detail the thing is or the
important message is that here we the
application of lsdm actually alleviates
the problem with vanishing or exploiting
gradients and demos I will be showing
they are actually based on our SDM
[Music]
the the lsdm based neural network so
first I would like to show the recurrent
neural network apply to the natural
language processing in the let's say
generative context so we'll be
generating some statements well I've
taken not myself I found on the Internet
the set of three thirty two thousand
tweets of current President of the
United States and I found also the on
the internet the predictive model which
has been trained on this on the streets
and will be in a few slides will be
somehow watching how the neural network
is producing the tweets so we have like
a three megabytes of text which is like
3.1 million of characters the dictionary
contains 98 98 characters upper lower
case digits we know that we have the
special characters in Twitter like the
hash tag or the mentions and the network
has been designed in such a way that we
been cutting the pieces of sixty
characters and introducing the this
matches the species into the neural
network as predictors and the next
character was the outcome so we will see
in a second how this look like how this
look like in practice
in a way I would like to encourage you
also to do the data science in localized
environment I yeah I will not go through
in detail through this one but the the
the the architecture or the presentation
you see now is based on Dockery's
environment dog arised environment built
from jupiter notebook and Minya Minya is
a private cloud used to withdraw the
files ok so let's go through the code so
i'm going to load the tweets so we have
the twitter data in the tweet date
variable and yeah this looks morals like
this so these are all the tweets
combined one after another and yeah the
learning process looks like this that we
have 60 characters long pieces of the
tweet and this is the predictor of
obviously one hot encoded and the next
character is just the response so we
more or less train the network in such a
way that we want to predict the next
character altogether we have something
like 3 million long training set and
yeah what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to create the neural network
recurrent neural network architecture I
use Cara's with tensorflow back-end here
and actually this is the vocabulary that
the entire set of characters and this is
the network like four four layers of
lsdm based units 512 nodes per each
layer at the end we have the activation
function as a soft Max and categorical
entropy as a loss function actually this
happens so the the model summary is the
following so we have these four layers
of lsdm nodes and which altogether means
that we have 7,600,000 network
parameters to be optimized so this is a
non-trivial optimization task to to
optimize this but this works so I'm just
loading now the previously trained model
which I found on the internet couple of
slides before I far I've provided a
github link to this repository where you
can just take it and do it by yourself
some helper functions and we will now we
are going to predict
we are going to do generative machine
learning so now the previously trained
on the Twitter data set neural network
is now producing new data so the seed is
just the incoming seed of the of the of
the of the tweet and then the the the
rest is done by the neural network so
you can see that somehow we have
incorporated the syntactic to properly
the syntactic part of English language
yeah and also you can see that all these
things like special features of Twitter
so has also been introduced tonight to
the to the network so dimensions and the
hashtags are used so it looks like a
tweet one can have let's say doubts
whether this make sense or not sometimes
the statements are out say surprising
sometimes they doesn't make sense but in
principle I think yeah we have
incorporated the syntax and also to some
extent the semantics of English language
yeah so more or less the summary of this
part is here yeah the important thing is
that the generated entities have the
features of real tweets like this
mentions and hashtags this is important
because now we'll switch to the
chemistry and you will see that the
language I will be incorporating to the
recurrent neural network the language of
molecules is also quite specific so the
recurrent neural network in chemistry
molecule are generation so what is this
- code smiles code is just the character
representation of molecules I'm going to
show in a few slides couple of examples
how this looks like it is from
mathematical point of view the molecule
by itself is just an undirected graph
where the nodes are the atoms and the
edges are chemical bonds yeah and the
smile specification is capable of
storing simplified information about the
molecules as a string of characters in
fact the molecule is a three-dimensional
species so where can
imagine that if we just take if we turn
the molecule into just this string of
characters then we'll obviously lose
some information smite is quite mature
it supports for example stereochemistry
of chiral compounds so it is well I
would say mature solution mature
specification you can see here just we
have some molecule and actually what we
do is we remove the hydrogen the light
atoms and what we do is we simply by
using an algorithm turn the order of
heavy atoms like a nitrogen carbon
carbon nitrogen and so on and so on in
string of characters obviously there are
rings so we have the parentheses to
reflect the ring and the smiles code
altogether one is able to turn each
molecule even the most complicated piece
of DNA or I don't know the some lipids
or proteins into string of characters we
can have a look at the example so for
example the simplest one of the simplest
molecule one can imagine is water as I
mentioned we don't put here the
hydrogen's the hydrogen's are redundant
so the smiles of Smiles coat of of water
is just o and then if we instant eight
molecule from the smiles code will
magically see the h2o which is water
there are more complicated things
methane ch4 we don't put the hydrogen's
they are implicitly somehow contained
even more complicated like butene for
four atoms four carbon atoms and a
couple of ten hydrogen 10 hydrogen atoms
and so on and so on so here we have not
a linear form of Boonton but this is
methyl isopropyl everything can be done
via smiles coding hexane similar and
then we have more complicated and
unsaturated compound yeah again the
double bonds is just introduced by equal
sign and the ring so we put a number one
here number one here and then magically
cyclohexane appears yeah and the benzene
the simplest possible aromatic compound
can be also introduced in the form of
Smiles code something more difficult
more complicated more complex ibuprofen
yeah here I didn't put the hydrogen's so
in the previous slides you could see
that there is this @h s function by the
way I'm using here some chem informatics
library to do all these things I have to
speed up a little bit because I don't
have a lot of time the ibuprofen was
there the caffeine we have a lot of
coughing over here and here also we have
some some coffee in again and instantly
ate it from just a smile scout so the
stereochemistry I don't know if you
remember from organic chemist or
district chemistry sometimes we have two
molecules and they are created in such a
way that they're mirror reflections or
it's impossible to put one molecule onto
another molecule if we consider two -
mirror reflections of these molecules
and as you can see here the
stereochemistry the s or our absolute
configuration can be introduced via this
sign so you can see here that here we we
got the floor in the bath the plane of
let's say screen and in this case we
have the fluorine behind the plane of
screen which exactly means that these
are different stereoisomers
so smile is mature smiles is capable of
doing a lot of things yeah also the chem
informatics libraries they allow to
calculate some molecular descriptors
like molecular weight
molecular weight of heavy atoms so here
we have ch4 we have one heavy atom which
is carbon with a mass 12 atomic units
number of valence electron 8 there are a
lot of other capabilities this is just
an example how one can use Python for
chemistry yeah we have at least two
important libraries like open babel and
our the kit both of them are used within
this study or both of them are open
source and they are we are very very
obviously friendly to the to the
scientists as Python is quite friendly
to the scientists the generation of new
molecules we are I've taken the database
of chemical molecules 13.5 gigabytes
this is the chem BL library this ya
1,800,000 distinct molecules some of
them have biological activeness well we
will not go through the nature of this
of this logic of this term but this is
ic50 this is a measure of the potency of
a substance to inhibit some specific
biological or biochemical function so it
means that if we introduce this more
this this compound to human or animal
body then something will happen actually
it's not neutral the molecules yeah so
I've taken just half a million of these
molecules with nonzero ic50 I have
turned these molecules into the smiles
codes and I've processed them into the
canonical form and actually what I did
is I have introduced exactly the same
approach which has been introduced for
this natural language processing I have
I've combined all the molecules into one
very long string and I have converged
the lsdm based recurrent neural network
so I have optimized this recurrent
neural network on the data set and then
I've been stimulating the network to
produce new molecular so we'll see this
actually right now
yeah I've applied the standard software
like a tensor flow Chara's this to
mentioned libraries also some data
persistence layer database persistence
layer access collide Postgres and other
python ecosystem to pre-process the data
there are some existing references so
people are doing research of this sort
so let's go through this prediction I
have only four minutes to do this
I'm just taking now this and it's this
might take a minute or something like
this is the data set of this molecules
from Mineo actually from this private
dock Erised cloud it's already in so
this is the CSV file with with the
molecule so you can see that there are
smiles code and some other let's say
descriptors of the molecule like number
of rings element set and so on and so on
the standard I mean the last column is
by the way it is I see 50 the standard
the mean value of I see 50 okay so the
molecules look like this actually some
randomly chosen molecules from this data
set so again you can see that this come
in from ethics libraries they provide
also the capabilities of visualizing the
molecules here and then here we have the
architecture of neural network so I'm
just now incorporating the model the
previously trained by myself model which
will be used in a few slides or one or
two slides to predict new molecules some
vectorization is taking place of this
may take a while yeah we'll see in the
next slide yeah the training has been
done on high performance computing
computational Center it took quite a lot
of time to converge this predictive
model
yeah I've received 80 till 55% of
accuracy depending on the attempt yeah
and the important thing is that in such
a non-trivial optimization of neural
network one has to
put a particular attention of learning
great so I've applied some heuristic
approach to manage the learning rate
because otherwise the network that does
not converge
so the yeah similar to the previous case
this is just my set of characters set of
string set of smiles codes as you can
see here there is from time to time Q or
e this is maybe before putting a Q now
there is a Q the Q is just a separator
so Q means that the molecules has just
ended and the next molecule is going to
start it's important during the
prediction phase because it will be
awaiting for the Q just to finish the
current molecule yeah and similarly to
the previous case the predictor is just
a sequence of given size given length
like 40 and next the next let's say
character in the string is just the
target so in this in this way the
predictive model has been trained of
course we have two one one hot end code
the atoms so the C in a sequence of
characters is just a vector the binary
vector with just one non false field
yeah altogether the new to the the
neural net modulus is a bit smaller than
the one before but again we I've created
this from lsdm units the prediction face
is exactly the same as before so we
introduce some sort of seed and then we
await well we predict the next molecules
and we await for for a Q which is just
the very end of the of the of the
molecule yeah and then I've did I done
I've done also some post-processing of
this of these molecules to get the 3d
object so let's go through so now we are
predicting that this is a seed and we
are predicting 2,000 characters long
string with supposedly new molecules
so this is my also a couple of seconds
I'm already after my time but we have
just say 1 or 2 minutes so I've just
created this 100 mm characters long
string and I have cutted the string into
molecules just by having this cue as a
separator so we've got something like a
73% of correctly predicted smiles smiles
molecules they look like this actually
so this these are new molecules some new
quality which just appeared from the
previously trains recurrent neural
network they look like this this is some
cleaning and we can have a look at them
so these are this new new molecules for
for being so so fast but I am out of
time at the moment yeah so this is keep
time so I'd like to go to the summary so
I've introduced the recurrent neural
network I've also introduced the natural
language processing funny but important
use case then I've been talking about
the smiles codes and the can informatics
libraries I lsdm based neural network
learned properly the syntax of smiles
code and I'm hoping that yeah this is a
superior assumption that together with
this syntax knowledge also the semantics
I mean this biological activeness the
factors that in the training set I had
biologically active molecules has also
been incorporated into the recurrent
neural network significant fraction of
generated smilest codes or reasonable
chemically correct molecules some of
them in statistical analysis turned out
that they are the repeated species from
the training set I have some more
research on the way and that's it thank
you very much thank you very much for
coming and thanks for your attention
you